this is a story of vulnerable people
like matthew leahy who sought help for
mental health problems just explain what
happened to matthew well i'd like to
know to be honest
he entered
he was taken to a so-called place of
safety which was the linden center in
chelmsford
and within seven days my son was dead
matthew was found hanged in his room at
the center in essex his inquest raised
questions about his care indeed he
didn't have a care plan it was
fabricated by staff after his death
now essex mental health services is
subject to an inquiry and the initial
findings are that over a 21-year period
1500 people died either as in patients
or within three months of being
discharged
this is the early stages of the inquiry
we don't know yet what proportion of
those deaths were suicide how many could
have been prevented but talking to
families the inquiry chair says that she
already has seen examples of
unacceptable dispassionate care
however 70 families many who've
campaigned for years are refusing to
take part in the review process because
they want a full statutory public
inquiry with the power to call witnesses
they say the scale of the deaths
reinforces their argument
that's 1500 souls 1500 boys girls women
dementia patients it's 1500 people and
how many families destroyed originally
you were told weren't you that there
weren't enough people for a public
inquiry exactly um yeah i think nadine
doris words were we do not do public
inquiries into just
one death well here we go we've got 1500
now how many more have to die before the
statutory powers are given
but the inquiry chair who's heard from
14 families so far says people should
have confidence
my message to those people is please
come and talk to us
please come and talk to us your evidence
is really really valuable
your evidence and your ideas about how
we should be feeding this forward
improving the system you have unique
evidence we really want to hear it these
are his friends a couple of his friends
some such as the wade family have chosen
to give evidence their son richard also
died in the linden center
he was there for less than 12 hours
before the injuries that he inflicted
upon himself
by hanging himself in a bathroom where
someone had hanged themselves not three
months before
it boils down to something really quite
simple they didn't care
we don't want it to happen to others
because it's awful it changes everyone's
life
you know with friends us
family it just you know i'm not the same
as i was before
you know
there you go
essex partnership university trust say
they continue to support the ongoing
inquiry and encourage patients family
carers and staff to share their
experiences with the inquiry team jason
farrell sky news